it seems Leonardo DiCaprio will stop at  nothing for the sake of art and raising  awareness about the environment  apparently the oscar-winner almost  drowned prior to making his new  documentary before the flood and  thankfully edward norton came to the  rescue I'm very lucky director Fisher  Stevens reveals to GQ the  life-threatening incident happened  during their first expedition to the  Galapagos Stevens was diving buddies  with Ed and Leo teamed up with  oceanographers silver Earl for the  underwater shoot he said quote Leo's  tank was leaking oxygen and Edward had  to save him it was pretty crazy but he  actually did get some film for me and it  was good for a second and then it got  pretty shaky when he couldn't breathe  but we really bonded on that trip  you